hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jessie today we're going to review
some pull requests and merge them and
we'll fix any merge conflicts that might
come up hopefully we don't get too many
but it would be cool to have some just
to show how to deal with it on the
stream before we get started I have
something just for fun so somebody that
I work with sent me this link earlier
and I thought it'd be cool just to show
it check this website out but good look
at how amazing this thing is it's just
like I I don't even know what to say if
as netscape 3.0 I think it's just I mean
obviously this was made as a joke but I
thought it was pretty funny
so anyway alright so let me let me take
the live chat quickly and say hi to
everyone and then we can we can get
started so since we are going to be
checking out the pull request if you
want to go to the repo you'll be able to
follow along with the pull request and
check them out for yourself we're gonna
start out with pool request number five
so the link to the repo is in the
description I'm also going to get this
end rock server running so that we can
all see the website together so I'm
pasting that in the live chat now and
all right let's see hey see lot of
people saying hey hey everyone
sebastian says i should use this design
for the next project uh-huh yeah so
anyway I just
it's amazing website if you view the
source code it's actually kind of it's
nice like there's not that many requests
Network requests everything's right
there in line so I admire oh and it
loads so quickly I don't know that
there's that much else to admire but at
least I can admire that now I'm I'm like
90% sure that that website was built as
a joke and they purposely made it look
like that so that's kind of fun all
right so let me bring over have a pull
request open on my other screen let's
bring it over so we can take a look at
it and let me make this bigger and
increase the font size okay let me know
if it needs to be larger font size but
okay so we have this pull request from
Sebastian I think in correct me if I'm
wrong Sebastian I think this is the pour
request that was submitted before the
stream yesterday and I had hoped that we
would be able to make the pull request
that we'd be able to merge the pull
request on the stream but it didn't
happen so the the cool thing is I
thought they were going to be merge
conflicts but it looks like Sebastian
after the stream went in and fixed the
merge conflicts so in this commit here
so we shouldn't have merged conflicts
I'll probably we're gonna check out some
of the files that have changed and then
we'll pull down a test branch just to
double-check I've already looked at some
of the codes so I I don't think there's
going to be any problems at all but it
would be cool to
go through I know I've done it before on
the stream but we'll just go through it
quickly and just do the test and then we
can merge it right there in the command
line so I think last time I didn't merge
it from the command line I think we did
it from inside the the green button the
big green button and github okay so
there's a lot of stuff changed in the
readme which is awesome so we had the
default read me from create react app
and now the readme is more specific to a
project so that's that's really great
that's one of those things that it's
like you always know you need to do and
you just keep putting it off so thank
you Sebastian for that and a lot of this
is just refactoring so we're not we're
not gonna see like new features involved
here but but if you can see I mean
there's significant saving of space
right a lot of these are going from
using the class-based components to the
functional components so definitely
saving some space there and let's also
just okay so the routes have been moved
into a separate file which is nice and
yeah this is a lot of a lot of switch in
the components to the functional
and they have says oh okay awesome
so not sure if you all notice this but
the background color was a different
color but it was just in this little
rectangle it didn't cover the whole
screen so there was this rectangle
towards the top of the screen that was a
gray a really light gray color so you
almost couldn't even see it if you
weren't really like paying attention to
it but it was annoying me and I I never
I went in in dev tools and figured out
where it was but I never went in to see
what part of the material UI theme it
was in so thanks Sebastian that was that
was actually annoying me quite a bit so
that's awesome
and let's see okay it looks like there's
a Styles folder so this got moved into a
Styles folder that's great and logo I'm
not sure what happened with the logo
here so maybe we have a new logo or has
it been to leave you completely I don't
know we'll see whenever we test it out
let's see
yeah this looks like a lot of just
refactoring the functional components
okay so now that we've gone through and
I obviously I skimmed through that I
looked at it a little bit more closely
before but really what I'm looking for
in a pull request are I mean anything
that stands out that's really major like
what happened there but also just to
double-check like is there anything
really weird in here that shouldn't be
in here
so now obviously Sebastian's been
submitting pull requests for a while so
okay I see Sebastian said the logo thing
that was the react logo so Sebastian
deleted the react logo so awesome that's
another one of those things when you use
create react app that you always end up
doing at some point but it's just kind
of if you don't do it right away it just
kind of stays around there until you
remember to do it but anyway if you have
a lot of people contributing to the
project you don't you don't always know
their intentions right so you would
think everybody would want to contribute
positively because I mean that's there
it's public you know that that if they
were to contribute some code that was
terrible or even malicious then you know
there'd be a record of it but it could
happen so I always do try to check like
I said now with Sebastian I'm not really
worried about anything like that but you
know since this is for you know my my
workplace I think I have a
responsibility to be able to check that
out if anybody ever asks me about it you
know I want to be able to honestly say
I've looked at every line of code before
I merged it to be confident you know
about that so I do try to look at every
line and make sure that it's all you
know it all works so I I think it's not
enough just to test the branch and see
if it looks okay you know in terms of
the front end I you got to look at the
lines of code
so that's easier with smaller pull
requests but the risk at least to me the
the risk of something getting in there
that shouldn't be in there is just too
high if it was a side project that I I
wouldn't really worry about it that much
but what I said for that since this is
for you know the university that work
for I'm a little bit more careful with
it so that's why I always go through it
now and I think we did this yesterday we
did this at some point within the last
week I think so this will be a little
review for those who who watched it if
you haven't watched it I'll explain this
as I'm going through and I forgot to
start my timer all right so we've
already taken in 12 minutes all right
I'm gonna do the 10 minute timer and
that'll put us right around 25 minutes
and then we'll do our first break for
questions if you're not familiar with
how we do the stream I do 25 minutes of
coding and then 5 minutes of question
and answer and then another 25 minutes
of coding after that we usually just do
the rest of the show as question and
answer but sometimes we do do some more
coding today we'll probably just do the
two sessions of coding so if you ask any
questions and I'm not answering a
question right away that's because I'm
gonna wait and answer during that
question-and-answer session so please
stick around if you don't have time you
can always watch the recording of this
video that's available on this YouTube
channel and I'll answer your question
whether whether you're here or not I'll
still do my best to answer the question
okay so let's do it first let's do a get
pool just to be sure we have everything
from our repo so that's always a good a
good move even if you're the only one
working on the project I have had this
happen before where I've done some some
work on a project from home or you know
from somewhere else and
gotten about it and then I go to work on
that project again later on and I don't
realize that I don't have all the the
changes so I don't have all the updates
so then I start making updates and try
to push it and then I have conflicts so
no matter what you should always start
the day off with a good pool all right I
happen to be up to date so we're good
and let's see and then on the other end
of things it's always great to if you
you know end the day with a push that
way anybody else working on the project
or if you have to work on the projects
from another location you have all the
code you need really you should be
pushing multiple times throughout the
day but at the very least you should end
the day with a push so let's do a get
fetch and we're gonna fetch origin the
pool request number five we're gonna get
the head and we're gonna call this s
refactor and let's see if we can do two
I don't think I have a branch like name
like this so for me this is just my
little naming thing you could you know
do whatever you want here but I'm saying
s for Sebastian and then this is mainly
a refactor and this is the second time
you submitted to refactor pool requests
so that keeps it straight for me in my
head but you can name things whatever
you want okay cool so we have this now
let's check out if you're not really
familiar with it you can have multiple
versions of your projects existing at
one time and they're they're called
branches so right now we're on the
master branch so this is one version of
our project we're going to switch now to
the branch that we just created and all
the code is going to switch over and
we'll be able to immediately see and
start working on this alternate version
and if we want we can combine versions
or we could go back in time to a
previous version so it's really helpful
for that it lets you kind of
I have the freedom to do whatever you
want and test different things without
worrying about messing up your project
beyond repair alright so let's do
refactor - okay awesome
when I die I test the pull request it's
a good idea to do yarn or NPM install in
case there are some packages now for
this pull request there aren't any new
packages but I'm just going to do it
just for demonstration that's weird it's
taking longer than normal okay so
there's no packages but if the person
who submitted the requests happen to
load a new NPM package and you didn't do
that then it probably wouldn't work it
would seem like the pull request is
broken when it's really not so that's
another good you know generally a good
thing to do
okay now you should already be able to
see this with an grukk if you've clicked
on that link and let me see I'm gonna
share that link again in case some of
you weren't here when I shared it the
first time you're getting the same error
okay it looks like there's some air
going on so let's check this out where's
my
is it here no I don't need this up
anymore I can't find where we had our
there it is I was on the screen already
okay so we're still getting that weird
error or at least I'm getting it here on
locally for me that I get that weird
error at first but then if i refresh it
it goes away so the next time that
happens let's take a look at that error
message and try to get that fixed I was
ignoring it yesterday but it's it is
getting kind of annoying so it'd be
better if we could get that fixed
all right so oh yeah
we're on the home page and let's bring
up our console just to check for errors
what do we have here
we're getting some sort of post error
for a three
I mean we're still getting our data so
let's do a refresh I'm gonna see huh
okay it looks like maybe that's where
the errors are coming from anyway let's
um it is let's do a check where is this
the layout the drawer let's just fix
this problem right now so it doesn't
bother us for the rest of the stream I'm
gonna do a check for to see if this
exists before we try to map through it
that way we won't get an error all right
George yes 54
okay so where a drawer all right cool
I'm already in this 54 all right we're
right here awesome okay so we want to
look for to see if data categories
exists so if data dot loading is false
and dated our categories exists then
we'll try to look for this let's see if
that does it okay not bad we didn't get
an error it's not exactly loading
everything but that's better than an
error now let's test it again with a
refresh and see what happens okay yeah
it's still I don't know if it's
happening on the end rot let's see I
guess I could check right now and see
let's get a little refresh okay yeah it
doesn't seem to be happening there so
I'm not sure at least we got rid of the
error message so I could work on that
later but for right now we're just kind
of testing things out so we're at the
category one page here and hmm okay this
is not working let's see if we do a hard
refresh if it works no it does not all
right
so we do have a problem okay so this was
working so quickly I'm going to switch
back to the master branch and see if
it's not working on the master branch if
it's not working on either branch then
maybe it's the WordPress installation
that's having the problem so I want to
rule that out right off the bat before
we start changing our code so check
master oops I mean oh yeah I did make
changes okay
I'm not gonna push that yet okay all
right so now we have master
Oh
okay so let's say that is working and
we're still getting these four or threes
but this is not working okay so all
right so this is all right this is a
good reason why you know we test things
out before we merge so let's go back and
look at the the diff so first place I'm
gonna look is in the category J S
component right because we did get the
homepage to load on that other branch
but not the category pages so I'm gonna
look there because the homepage shares
some of the other components so the
problems shouldn't be in those so let's
check it out
we'll look there first and if we can't
find it there then we'll look at that
particular piece of code that's getting
the data for that component J s or that
category J s component so we should have
this open and we do oops let me I didn't
want to look there I wanted to look here
so let's find if anything changed in
category which I believe it did
ergo category all right now we're going
to go through this particular file a
little bit kind of more slowly and pay
attention to what's going on here
okay so we've just done some refactoring
she's fine this should work render cat
all right so far that looks identical at
least that render categories part let me
go up here and see
all right let me check the live chat see
if you all saw anything
okay I don't see anything right now
all right I want to do this entire thing
and walk through this
alright let's go back to our back to our
other branch so we're gonna go back to
other branch and we'll let this load now
we've taken care of the error message
which is good that we did that because
now we'll be able to inspect and see a
little bit behind the scenes so what's
going on so let's go into react right
now and see what kind of props we have
category here all right so there's some
error
okay so it looks like our data so we're
not even getting the proper data we're
getting an error message back
Oh
okay Sebastian has a thought here about
the the URL so maybe somehow the URLs
didn't get let me try to get back if you
might be onto something I let's think
I don't remember what it was but yep
that's it I but I think this is it all
right right so somehow probably when you
were handling the merge conflicts
somehow the previous way that we handle
these got mixed in so if you remember at
the end of yesterday stream we were able
to use the category slug instead of the
ID so right now we're still using the ID
here so the IDS getting passed in but
the graph QL API is expecting the the
slug so it's returning nothing because
we're not giving it a slug we're giving
it an ID all right so that's that's not
a big deal that's a pretty easy fix so
in this case I'm not going to throw out
the pool request because of this right
let's get the fix test it and then if
that's the only thing that's wrong then
the rest of the pool request is
perfectly fine and we can just merge it
in so let's go in here to probably it'll
be our routes right so that was the we
have our routes file somewhere else now
where is it
routes here we go okay so here's our
routes okay so it does say slug here so
that's fine let's go back to our
category then maybe it's here at the
bottom that's firm slug no we are we are
giving the slug in here let me up let me
double check and make sure
ok let's check our drawer and see there
it is that's what we need to change so
this node ID needs to be node slug ok
let's see you know what I want to double
check to make sure this is the latest
version occasionally when I switch
branches it doesn't update an atom right
away so let's make sure we have the
right one
and now let's check this out okay so
instead of ID let's put slug and this
should fix everything so go back to the
home page
let's refresh all right now when we
click on category one good we have the
right great thing in URL here category
two wonderful that way three awesome
oops
actually this shouldn't be worries
yeah let's take out this link because we
don't need this to be a link this is
just a section header so I'm gonna take
that out right now while we're we're
already here so categories is not gonna
be a link it's just gonna be a list item
and
let's see what that that looks like
okay it still looks like you can click
on it but you can't for now what we'll
need to do is we'll go in and change
this up so it doesn't have these styles
like a button at some point I'm not
worried about that right now
we'll take care of that whenever we get
you know everything in here and then
we'll really start to style this exactly
how we want it but it's not really a
point in trying to style it now and so
we have it all filled out with with what
we want okay awesome
all right cool Sebastian says glad you
found that issue this is why you always
review and test PRS before merging yeah
definitely I'm actually I'm really glad
that that happened for two reasons one
it was awesome just to show like hey it
it was good that we were taking our time
with this pull request because we caught
this before it got merged into master I
mean can you imagine if this was a
production application right and we
didn't test it thoroughly and we pushed
that out to production right immediately
we would have users getting errors so
right now the stakes are pretty low
because it's still just you know kind of
local here but you know in a more mature
project that's actually live it could
have been disastrous the second reason
why I like this and I hope Sebastian
won't get mad at me for saying this is
I'm really used to me being the one that
messes up that makes a mistake so so at
this time it was it happened to be
Sebastian just missed that one little
thing which I hope you don't mind that I
was just kind of making fun of you a bit
Sebastian but you've been here with the
live in in the streams and everything
for a long enough time that I think
we're ok to do that also
realistically Sebastian did a lot of
really good stuff in that pool request
the fact that he was able to do all that
and only have one tiny little mistake I
mean literally that's it right I mean
that's huge because the
the fixing all those merge conflicts was
probably a big deal I was not looking
forward to have to do having to do all
that I was really happy when I saw that
Sebastian did that so anyway so I'm just
messing with you a little bit I know how
hard it is to go through and get all
those merge conflicts sorted out all
right awesome
so now really quickly I'm just going to
click around just to make sure that we
hit every view all right this didn't
have a an image right let's click one
that did Evan M is just double check
okay cool and that's it we don't really
have a lot of views yet so that should
be as we've tested our category view we
tested our home view and our post
detailed view that's it that's all we
have and it looks like for some reason
we're still getting four or threes let
me clear this out and do a refresh let
me do a hard refresh because you know
how for some reason we're getting that's
really weird
mmm single post detail query variables
ID
okay so I mean we're sending what we're
supposed to be sending let me check my
time oh I knew I had to be out of time
okay
and again for some reason I'm not
getting the the beat usually I get I
hear a beep I got it working for a few
days and I'll quit again okay let me
take now five minutes and go through the
live chat and answer some questions then
we'll come back and merge this in I
think I'm gonna have to double check in
the slack channel for our WP graph QL
plug-in I think someone else was getting
four or threes but basically I'm not
like I said I'm have to double check but
from what I remember I think even though
it's sending four or threes it's also
sending the data that we need so it's
working it's just the errors are coming
through so I'm not that worried about it
right now I do want to double check but
I think it shouldn't affect us you know
other than having those errors in the
console but it shouldn't affect us right
now we'll be safe to you know move on
with the rest of the development of our
app all right short break five minutes
I'm gonna scroll to the top and get
through as many questions as I can again
I see a lot of a lot of you saying hi so
hey everyone hey I'm a I would love to
be able to go through everyone's name
and say how do you all personally but
the stream would probably be really long
if I did that but I do I do read them
all I see all of your name so I
appreciate it
denaun J says asks how how are you says
how are you buddy
actually I'm really good now once the
stream started I'm really good but to
tell you the truth all day I was super
distracted and just felt like no
motivation at all I had to work with
some other people's code from another
company that we're contracting out too
do some stuff and it was said it made me
want to cry really it was an angular
application and that wasn't the problem
the problem was like they were loading
so many different things they didn't
need it was like 72 Network requests for
one page that had minimal stuff on it
I'm it just had a couple of links it was
insane
and I was trying to change the styles
and they had stuff in style sheets that
were LinkedIn they had stuff in style
tags in the head
they had inline Styles it was just all
over the place and trying to get
everything to override what it needed to
it took way longer than I hoped it would
take and that's like not even it's not
even one of my official projects it's
just some other thing that I was helping
out with because because I care how the
university sites look even if they're
not ones that I built anyway so that's a
little bit about how I'm doing but the
streams always cheer me up and break me
out of whatever weird mood I'm in
ego says I should not have looked at
that link in the chat now I'm hungry so
Eva looked at the site and so the
delicious looking meat so as long as
you're not a vegetarian that I would
probably be tasty it will probably look
tasty tea oh cool so coup de quash a
sorry if I'm mispronouncing that but I
think it's coup de quoi Shay says hey
Jesse what's up
this is coup de casa all the way from
Zimbabwe awesome thanks for joining us
I don't know if you've been in previous
streams or not if I've seen that but if
not welcome and I'm not sure I don't
know if we've had anyone from Zimbabwe
so far I mean we may have and they just
didn't say they were from Zimbabwe but
welcome
that's it
Blake says I'm watching the force
awakens' cool I just watched the trailer
for the new Star Wars is anybody in the
live-chat a Star Wars fan so I I wasn't
gonna watch the new trailer because I
was afraid it would give away too much I
just wanted to be surprised but then I
talked to the head of my department is a
big star Wars fan and she she was
telling me that she was really excited
after watching the trailer and she
assured me that there weren't any bad
spoilers so I decided to watch it so it
was cool it got me excited I didn't get
goosebumps like the force awakens
trailers gave me goosebumps when I first
saw them but so I didn't get that level
but it was still good I'm so excited for
it
okay so ref says I think it's better to
do small working logical commits so it's
easier to for someone to review it and
he doesn't like to read a thousand lines
of code okay I agree yeah so I think I
mentioned this at some point this week I
do prefer that so being on this side of
things and having to review pool
requests I definitely realize like what
what makes the pull request easier to to
handle so if you're submitting so be
honest with you if you all take the time
to submit I'm gonna review a pull
request no matter what and do my best to
make it work because I really appreciate
your time you know and volunteering that
but if you're submitting to other
repositories and you really want to get
your pull request merged then try to
make it small and really to the point
like just change one thing think about
it like when you're making a react
component you want that component to
just do one thing ideally right and you
break your site up into all these little
chunks think the same way when you're
doing your pull requests is that you
want your pull request to do one
specific thing that you can clearly say
this is what it does succinctly and
someone could go through and easily see
what changes were made in just a minute
or two you're much more likely to get
your pull requests merged if you do that
because the maintainer x' will be able
to get through it quickly and be sure
that it's not going to mess anything up
so that's my I'm certainly no expert if
you look at my github repo I haven't
gotten a lot of pull requests merged
probably the number one reason is I'm a
little bit overwhelmed with my workload
right now not just here at work but in
the courses that I'm taking on the side
and before I had a course I had a client
that was had a big project so at some
point when I get through this course I'd
really love to try to give back
some of those repositories that you know
I've used and benefited from so I'd love
to be able to do that so recognize I'm
not really an expert but I do review
pool requests and I know what's easy and
what's difficult all right so I'm done
with my five minutes of
question-and-answer so I'm gonna
remember where I left off at and and
I'll come back to there after we get
done with our next 25-minute
coding session oh those says the audio
is too loud it's clipping let me know if
anybody else is hearing some distortion
in the audio or something let me know I
did remember to move my phone farther
away but I have it connected to my
computer and the cord is somewhat close
to the mic so maybe that's interfering
so let me know because I don't want okay
it looks like audio is okay all right so
whatever it was it's I guess it's not
happening anymore
also I noticed my audio is kind of off
so at the beginning of the video it's
okay but towards the end of the at least
of the recordings the audio is not
synched with my mouth so I don't know if
it's like that during the stream or not
I guess you all have to let me know but
it's it's somewhat annoying well I've
been going back and watching a little
bit of the stream the previous streams
I'm not really sure what I can do about
that though I'll have to look it up if
anybody's familiar with OBS and uses it
let me know how you fix the issue of
everything getting out of sync okay all
right let's go we're gonna get we're
gonna get this pull request merged in
and we have another pull request that's
much smaller so it shouldn't be quite as
much work to go through the code and
let's see oops what I'm looking for my
terminal
where I'm going here okay okay so we did
modify this what did we do here
okay we had to change that that's right
I didn't realize we hadn't committed
that yet okay so if you're not familiar
with yet what I just did there was I did
a status to see if we had anything that
had changed that we didn't commit yet
and we did and I couldn't remember what
I changed so I did it get diff and then
that shows us what's changed our layout
our drawer j/s component and it'll
actually show me so the red is things
that have been deleted right and the
green is what has been added so we can
see right here in our console what has
changed so now I know what's changed and
I got out of that by pressing Q now I
can commit this since I know what it was
this changed
so we're gonna do a git commit the a
flag means we're gonna add and commit at
the same time we're combining two steps
the M means we're going to put a message
in line here so our commit message will
be use
all right so you slug instead of ID for
category links there we go alright so
now I'm not gonna push this right away
I'm gonna merge first and then just push
it all up right to the master branch so
what I always like to do first and it
shouldn't we shouldn't have any merge
conflicts because they've already been
taken care of by Sebastian but what I do
like to do first is do a git merge
master
so I'm merging master into our current
branch or s refactor to branch and then
that way if there are a bunch of
conflicts we haven't messed up our
master branch and kind of locked it up
we'll lock up this branch and then we
can always switch to master right
because what we want to avoid is a
situation where we try to merge
something in a master there's all these
merge conflicts we're starting to work
through it we're halfway through all
these merge conflicts and then we get an
emergency and we need to change
something on master right away and push
it up to production well now what are we
going to do right it's it's going to be
much more difficult there you know there
are ways to stop that to cancel a merge
right but it you see how it could get a
little bit messy but if we do it like
this if that happens all we have to do
then is just switch back to our master
branch we can even commit some of the
stuff that we've done all right we can
cancel our merge what you do whatever
you want with it because it doesn't
matter it's a side branch right so we
can go back to master make our changes
come back to our other branch and then
merge those new changes back in and then
once we're satisfied with everything and
there's no conflicts then we take it
back to master so hopefully that makes
sense but so I said with this project
it's still small its local probably not
an issue but it's good to have you know
the good habits even on the small
projects and then you'll remember it
when you have the the bigger projects
okay so now we're gonna go back to
master and we're going to merge this
into master so from our master branch
we're gonna do get merge and we're gonna
merge in that branch we were just on
there we go so now we get our message it
just gives us a little summary of what's
been done right so it'll say in the case
of like the readme right we've deleted
quite a few lines by we I mean Sebastian
has deleted go ahead a few lines and add
it a bit right so we get a little
summary I usually don't look at this too
much because at this point I've already
reviewed all those lines right this
shouldn't be the first time you're
looking at the lines right because you
review before you merge but this should
work so again let's check out
okay in my back now it looks like
alright awesome back on I don't know
what happened well it seems like my
internet cut out the weird thing was you
know my icon seemed like it was you know
the network was fine just really weird
okay
okay
hey we just got an error report from
something that we made so maybe if we
get this other pool crest merged in
quickly maybe let's take a look and and
check out this error report from the
resource center one of the forms on the
research center that we just did that
was projects - so that might be cool to
check out alright so for now let's make
sure that this works okay it works it
was definitely just my connection that
was causing the problem and all right so
if you see on our our pool requests oops
let me go back to the main one our pull
request oh we didn't push it back up
sorry
so let's go get push origin master this
will push everything up to get up now
what we should see is it's merged see so
everything's merged and grid
okay cool so we have that merged in
let's check out our next pool request
and let's see so not really an
explanation yet right because it's
really small but Sebastian has pointed
something out here so let's check it out
all right that's a really good point
so smashing noticed if we have our our
drawer basically on large screen sizes
we own our drawer to be open
automatically with the do you want the
option to shut it or we know we remove
the option to shut it so on smaller
screens the drawer is going to be closed
but we do have somewhat of a problem if
we make the screen larger so let me
demonstrate this now we should be able
to demonstrate this problem Oh actually
I thought we removed this maybe I
removed it at some point and then it
didn't get merged in right anyway let's
let's pretend like we don't have this
here because I'm pretty sure we had
decided we're gonna remove it so we're
on a small screen and we make it bigger
do we have no we do we have that button
we still can do it alright let's um I
guess the problem is nut is the other
way right now when we go to a smaller
screen if we didn't have this button
which we probably won't to close it it's
really unusable so we would need you
know something to handle that the only
time this would really come into play I
would imagine is in you know the
potentially rare case that someone has a
large smartphone and they're in
landscape mode when they load the site
and then they flip it to portrait mode
that's probably the only case that I
would think that someone would that that
would happen that we would need to worry
about now I mean obviously we need to
have something and that's what Sebastian
let's check out what Sebastian's
solution was so there's a responsive
drawer with material UI and it looks
like looks like harsh it's gonna handle
that so
this pool requests
okay so it's I think what's going on
here and let me know
I don't think our shoots watching but
Sebastian let me know I think what
happens is the the change that you had
talked about here has not been
implemented yet is that correct if so
maybe we'll hold off on merging this in
because it seems like hardship was
planning on doing that so maybe I'll
just give it another day and I'm fine
doing it as well but in fact I would
probably do it on the stream right now
if I didn't get this error report in
okay cool
so let's let's put this on hold and
since this is kind of still in process
here we'll give it we'll give it another
day maybe tomorrow to be ready let me
check my time okay ten minutes all right
so we have another ten minutes or so of
coding time I just got an error report
from someone who works with me here in
our project number two so let's check
this out if if you don't know already
this stream is just me doing my daily
work so while I try to have a certain
topic and stick to that sometimes things
come up and I have to deal with it so in
this case this is one of those times we
have people who are trying to submit
things through the Resource Center and
they're getting an error message and
they're not able to submit so at first I
thought maybe you know they're being
thrown off by this button being disabled
maybe they haven't filled out all the
required fields but I've just got
confirmation now that that's not the
case what's happening is users are
trying to upload more than one file on
the file upload and it's not letting
them which is a bit weird
so the
the test case that I'm I got tried to
upload two PDFs so let's first try to
recreate this so the test case was done
on a Mac on Chrome so we should be good
to recreate it here so let's try to find
two PDFs
let's see it says okay cool
and I know I just showed you all my
address and phone number I don't care if
you call I don't answer my phone I let
everything go to voicemail so if I don't
answer leave a message and I don't care
about my dress being out there too
because when I was a freelancer my
business was listed at my home address
so all it takes is a Google search to
find it let's see let's try to find I'm
gonna try to recreate this as closely as
possible
so let's find PDFs I think I should have
some PDFs in my downloads I actually
might make my documents PDF budget codes
and okay so I'm gonna grab this bulletin
and this budget code PDF
and let's open those and we'll try to
upload them okay
well that didn't work all right I'm
gonna try this now I've noticed Kevin
notes notes watt note solo says hey you
are crazy I'm heading straight to your
huh
I really don't think it takes that much
effort to find out someone's address
right
like people are listed in phone books
it's really I don't know it's such a
minor inconvenience I don't worry about
it like to be honest with you I have an
alarm system so I live out in the
country all my neighbors have guns like
it's not really a huge it's not like I'm
really afraid that much of people coming
out so let's see okay I do want to know
it I did I noticed in the file upload
here they had some spaces in the name
Crona says can I go chill with you for a
bit around 7:00 p.m. I'll be putting my
kids to sleep around 7:00 p.m. so you
can come chill and just hang out until
I'm done putting the kids to sleep
actually what's the date today oh it's
the 12th tomorrow the new season of
Voltron comes out on Netflix so I'll be
watching that with my kids at 7 p.m.
tomorrow I'm checking to get the hmm
okay here we go I should have got that
request all right so it did go through I
got confirmation by email that that
request went through I'm gonna
double-check now that it went to our
project management system I'm doing this
on my other screen just in case there's
any projects that are like shouldn't be
released yet that I don't want to put it
on YouTube
okay yep the files did come through
harnesses I don't get shot that yeah
yeah if somebody if you come to my house
and you want to hang out and you don't
want to get shot then maybe just call me
ahead of time or send me a message let
me know don't let come banging on my
door at one o'clock in the morning cuz
I'll be freaked out other than that it
should be okay you know I don't wear
like a ski mask and creep around in my
yard as long as you don't do that you
should be fun I actually did I had a
neighbor once that came through they
came in like I was already asleep and he
was banging on the door and then he went
around to the back door surveying on the
back door so I got up and I'm like he
was trying to get in my house so I
grabbed the gun and I'm going to the
door and it's the neighbor so I realized
it was a neighbor I put it behind my
back so I didn't freak him out but I
mean we had recently moved into the
house and I wasn't sure like about the
neighborhood or anything so I was pretty
freaked out but I I definitely would not
shoot first though so I'll give you a
chance to explain yourself I'm not sure
how to recreate this I don't think I
don't think I'm gonna be able to
recreate this here on the stream I'm
gonna need to go to I'm just gonna go to
this person's computer because she's
like three offices down for me so after
I end the stream I'm gonna go check it
out she's also taunting me in the slack
channel by saying there pumpkin cookies
and they're not gonna be any left by the
time I finished streaming so I okay so
here's what we would do
I know we have two minutes left or so
but we're just going to start the
question answer session a little bit
sooner
I had hoped we'd be able to figure this
out but I mean if you've ever tried to
replicate issues you know sometimes it
can take a while so I don't want to just
you know keep trying a bunch of things
and come up empty
on the stream if I find the issue though
I'll let you all know tomorrow if I
forget and you're interested just remind
me in the stream tomorrow and we can go
over what the problem was
let's see let me go back to where I left
off in the live chat okay
oh cool rook says while that branch
change did update the code incredibly
quickly time to learn more about get
yeah for sure
get as get is awesome I can't believe I
don't even remember what I did before I
used to get definitely changed the way
that I worked for the better if you do
want to you to learn get I recommend you
dasa d has a free get in github course
that's excellent and there are some
videos on on this channel the free code
camp Channel about get I didn't do them
but I haven't really watched the free
code camp once so I can't personally say
talk about their quality but I mean
usually free code can't videos are are
pretty good quality so I'm confident
about that and then code Academy has a
free get course as well if I out of the
three for me like I said I didn't watch
the videos but the most helpful was the
Udacity get course
okay Blake says yes is there a weight
and eat the way to easily fetch data
from a wordpress site and render it on a
plain HTML site yeah definitely here's
what I would do you have a plain HTML
site you want to use you can either use
fetch which I recommend using you maybe
have to use a polyfill if you want to
support older browsers if you're already
loading jQuery you could use Ajax but
one of those two I'd recommend using and
then you can just basically when the
page loads or on click or something like
that you can use the WordPress REST API
the rest api would probably be the
simplest so you use the rest api make
your api call so you would just send a I
think it's a get request with the word
to the REST API you'll get the data back
and you can render out however you want
on the page just using some some
JavaScript and like I said if you
already need to load jQuery for
something it makes it even easier but
you certainly don't need to have it so
that's how I would do it if you want to
know more about doing it trying to think
if I have any public repos where I do
that
actually I do I'm pretty sure I do let
me let me find the repo right now at
least you can have an example the
example might be a bit outdated I don't
know that if I'm using fetch or not I
might be using Ajax let's see
okay I think it's this one so this one
called WP API isotope this was just kind
of like my first one of my first
attempts to use the WP API so I wanted
to use isotope which basically gives you
a nice masonry layout I wanted to get
posts from the WordPress API and display
them in that masonry layout using
isotope so this is what I came up with
and you can see in the app das file
I do have let me find there we go okay
so here okay I am using Ajax so in this
case I'm getting all the categories and
so I have jQuery I'm using Ajax I put in
the base URL is actually this demo site
that we're using for our project now and
then I tag on WP - JSON / WP / v2 and
then in this case / categories and then
I'm also adding per page 100 so I get
you know more than just the base
categories by default you'll get 20 that
would be sufficient for now we don't
have a lot of data on the demo site but
if we had more you know we want to get
more so I'm getting that and then I'm
taking that data which is and I'm
filtering
I'm sorry not filter I'm iterating over
that data and I'm appending it so I'm
appending it to my Dom element with a
class of filters I'm appending these
options I'm using a template literally
or to make it you know more simple but
basically I'm just popping in that data
in a similar way that we would do it in
a react component so I'm mixing in the
HTML markup and the JavaScript
using the template literal and that's
how we would add it into the DOM and
display it right so I'm doing a similar
thing with the tags here and I'm doing a
similar thing with a post as well so I
have some different options in here but
if you want to check that out that'll
let you know at least using jQuery how
to do it it wouldn't be that much of a
stretch to look at this and figure out
how to do it in vennett with vanilla
JavaScript and fetch but anyway
hopefully that helps
all right Eric says this is really great
info I've been beginning these alerts
for live streams from free code camp for
a while and wish I would have watched
more I'll certainly keep up with these
awesome glad you decided to watch and
I'm glad you liked it
so thanks for saying that and thanks for
watching hopefully we'll see you in here
for some future streams
all right Sergio says hey Jesse thank
you for your live videos you're welcome
thanks for watching and oh cool Sergio
says I'm working on the readable Udacity
project
oh okay awesome yeah let me know how
that's going the readable one I just
finished that one recently that was a
tough one I think that's the redux one
where you make like a blog with Redux
and you can do voting I should I should
you all in a live stream a week or two
ago it was the real like retro-looking
one anything he said Star Wars for Life
OK JH k k JH K says what is github okay
Anthony answered it's a powerful tool
for code collaboration and version
control yeah yeah so git is the version
control system that you can use on your
local machine and then github is a
website where you can store your git
repositories which is all your code and
the different versions of your code in
the history of all the updates to your
code and it also allows you to code with
other people so other people can
collaborate easily on your project and
you can still have control over what
code you allow into your project from
other people so very very useful
now Sergio says got guts stacked many
times but it's an awesome react Redux
app to learn from got stuck though it's
been a few days and I totally understand
how that goes I was stuck like so many
so many times I get stuck and frustrated
but keep at it keep at it and if you
haven't already make use of the live the
live chat feature so if anybody is
taking a course from Udacity a paid
course there's a live chat feature and
that can be really helpful so if you've
been stuck for a while you know use that
and they'll they'll definitely help you
out and get you over you know whatever's
giving you trouble there and even if if
you get to the point where you're like
almost finished and you're not sure you
can always submit the project get the
feedback and then try again that's
that's really helpful
okay scar says which server are you
using node yeah I'm yeah so it's node is
is what we're running everything from so
I mean right now it's local and then I'm
using something called a service called
end rock so that everybody can check it
out on their own machines and then once
we go live it'll be running on a
digitalocean droplet with Ubuntu and
nginx set up as a reverse proxy and then
node with Express will be what's you
know what's actually running the bat
okay so the the chubs to the Maxis is
there a file upload size yeah actually I
should check that I am gonna check
whenever I go check with my colleague
about this issue as soon as I'm done
with the stream I'm gonna check her file
sizes and see if that could be the issue
if they're just really big files and
then maybe we can increase the file size
I can't remember for sure if we set that
or what we set it at Sebastian says
she's not using Internet Explorer right
no she knows better than that all right
Robert also asked if there are any file
size limits so I'm definitely gonna
check on that that's a good idea
abdul-aziz says is it possible to have
two profiles in both github and code pen
I guess so I mean you just need an email
address for those right so if you had a
different email address you could have
multiple profiles okay Blake says the
the free code camp get videos are pretty
good but not in depth though okay that's
good to know
the Udacity course does get in-depth and
that you actually have like test
projects that you clone onto your
machine and you submit pull requests and
things so if you want to get it more
into that and handling like merge
conflicts and stuff then I recommend
that course Blake says when I'm using a
CDN should I use magnified or standard I
would always use minified if I'm using a
CDN because there's no need for you to
read that code you're not going to be
able to edit it right because it's on
the CDN if you were using a local copy
and wanted to make changes to it then
you know go with the standard but
otherwise I don't really know of a
reason why you'd want to use manuf ID
unless you're just curious and wanted to
learn more about how things are done
okay Sebastian sent a form from the
resource center let me do let me check
it out now to see if I received that
that form so let me check
I did not get it yeah I didn't get
anything
let me yep
I did not get it oh you mean that one
okay not now yeah actually I did so it's
about Sebastian I did get that and it
had some of the exploits and I i fixed
that so I used an NPM package that will
strip out all of that stuff so thank you
for for sending that so that was base
the day I found out that they they
actually would only run under certain
circumstances so if you happen to open
it in a browser based email client a
particular browser-based email client
and then hit reply you could get a
script tag to run so it was a very
specific case when it would happen but
it was still possible so now it strips
out you know any script tags as well as
it helps protect against some other
things too so if you're interested in
that you can check out the repo for that
project that's the the Resource Center
project and see you know some of the
later commits will have that that in
there I can't remember for sure if it
was the last commit but it's close to it
okay Blake ass what's the difference
between the minified and the non
minified code and sebastian answer says
minified it removes all spaces and the
code is basically two long lines and the
standard way it's it's a readable code
yeah so you'll see I mean literally
everything there'll be no spaces it will
be a huge long mine a lot of times the
variable names will get changed to just
letters so it'll be like ABCD so it's
really hard to read and figure out
what's going on that's why I say use
minified if you're going into production
and you don't need to read it you just
want it to load faster because it's a
smaller file size otherwise you standard
if you need to be able to read it and
figure out what's going on
okay all right so I've reached the
bottom of the live chat and I'm gonna go
now because I really want to figure out
what's going with going on with this
error and fix it so I'll be back what's
today's yeah it's Morris Friday well so
I should be back tomorrow I'll I'll
tweet about when I'm gonna stream and
also schedule it so you should get a
notification if you're subscribed to
this channel thank you so much for all
your help this was a pretty nice stream
I didn't really do that much in this
stream but it was it was nice it was
kind of a relaxing the stream hopefully
you all learned something about git and
github and I had a great time so thank
you all for for being involved in the
live chat for watching and until
tomorrow have a great day